[Música]
ae
o gol gaúcho caso muito meninos iam
gostar de que um super suprimento que já
queria fazer há muito muito tempo eu
aqui há uns tempos teve um vídeo na
internet em que um sujeito uma pessoa
quando estados unidos basicamente o que
eu fiz foi inventar uma máquina de lavar
roupa com uma pedra
quebre essa que nós temos aqui também
olha só mas antes nós tentaremos colocar
a pedra aqui dentro e ver o que acontece
lá que já sabe o que vai acontecer isso
vai tudo depois
espero é de fazer um disco nós vamos
tentar com outros objetos que ficou mega
fone com uma cunhada do funk naide com
uma lata de spray
eu espero que isso tem lá dentro porque
komba a editar tudo isso aqui bate por
exemplo mas basicamente é isso que nós
vamos implementar aqui pessoal e não sei
se vai funcionar a primeira vez que um
bom tentar eu até já tive que fazer uma
coisa na máquina olha só essa máquina
aqui é especial porque ela vai funcionar
sem a nossa tampa tempo contemplar é
porque normalmente essas máquinas que só
funcionam com tempo fechado por uma
questão de segurança então já fiz aqui
um pequeno texto com essa pessoa aqui e
por isso a máquina vai achar que ela
está fechada em na verdade não está
então nós vamos conseguir fazer este
experimento com a tampa aberta podem ver
pessoal a ficha já tá ligada desde lá de
trás
olha isso já está tudo a postos e agora
é só clicar no botão mas antes nos
legaram de que nossa máquina de lavar
roupa eu preciso que vocês deixem muito
é que neste vídeo porque este primeiro a
ser muito perigoso pode ser perigoso
porque a pedra pode saltar quando tem um
olho após ficar cego não vai acontecer
na produção vai acontecer e não não não
aparentemente a produção quer que eu
morra mas isso não vai consertar tudo
seguro aqui mas só deixei muito claro
que quiser ver mais vídeos destes cinco
mais precoce com com eletrodomésticos
sempre que pensar em fazer mais tanto
cometem muitos deixem muito mais que
isso não foi inscrito no canal sul em
comum
força bora lá então começar o nosso
teste pessoal black comentário palavra
pessoal da máquina funciona e em 32 o
pai não está a funcionar victor está
distante ou a funcionar como vai rodar
no externo a voltar a rodar bairro natal
marcos está muito índice estava em padre
operacional é isso o que é isso
imagina manter a cabeça lá dentro eu
sempre quis fazer isso eu vou tentar
fora soubesse o que vocês acham banda já
documentei hora 3 de junho vai ai ai ai
eu vou colocar a câmera
meu deus isso é muito estranho e não é
muito longo porque faz muito calor
dentro do total e por um assessor do ser
humano
vamos lá estar sob a nossa máquina está
fora há muito rápido olha isso aí eu já
estava no nosso pé e isso é um problema
dela baixou 3 descontar funcionava em
calma muita calma comité cacá silva
meu deus passar tudo isso desde bora
bora bora bora e en 321 vai isso não era
meio que cria a lei falta chegar à
quinta irão conferem caiu a ficha limpa
to desapareceu
eu até fiquei mesmo junto ao tambor está
pintado bota pintado e dentro disso não
liberou o problema do anel e olha lá o
solo foi um texto bem pequena e agora
está com uma coisa amanhã aí uma pinhata
vamos lá ver alguns em 123 mais o op
isso ajuda muito
meu deus nem consigo acreditar nela e
assim só ficou à nossa caminhada até
pobre 12 toque de gênio bilhões oxigênio
mostra pessoal é presentemente com
outras coisas a máquina não faz o mesmo
efeito eu estava com a nossa pedra eu
acho que vai agora pessoal vamos colocar
a nossa pedra não ainda não opera ainda
não é agora vamos entrar com uma coisa
mais pesada que o nosso megafone falei
com ela só a nossa máquina está muito
rápida e em 32 um mega-fone chapa nós a
fazer isso
a cabeça é salvar os filhos megafone
eu nem dá pra ganhar na bola pessoal
segundo momento a máquina está na
multidão máxima e agora sim vamos
colocar a nossa penal e dentro dela a
cara dela aí eu vou fugir um
[Música]
abriu a gaveta
aí tudo ali dentro
[Música]
não vejo também vai chamar olha ai olha
aí foi a introdução ou procurado alguma
[Música]
maneira como é que se chama isto é 10 00
o
a alcançar o posto que já partiu os
vidros cofres visto que esta máquina não
funcionou como eu queria ter que
destruir é mas tendo em conta que este
experimento que ia ser uma destruição eu
acabei por comprar uma máquina muito
fraca então se nós conseguirmos chegar
aos 100 mil leques neste vídeo vou
comprar uma máquina mais potente e aí
sim eu acho que vai jogar bem porque ela
roda mais rápido e só se miletic neste
vídeo eu vou descansar vou tomar um chá
sim vou dormir feliz fica meio até a
próxima